ela começa a gravar hoje um gravando em
que 77 silence aí galera que a música
nova uma chapa você espera que você
curta ou insones leonel moreira
vamos nessa única para j
haha
ela é daquelas que tu pensa que tem
nariz empinado mas quando tu precisa
matar aqui do meu lado menina de
respeito
esse é o seu jeito tem um abraço gostoso
eu lavo tá ligado a ela tome uma
princesa e copa do maranho acorda mais
feliz por saber que ela é só minha
bom dia carinhoso também já meu pescoço
meu coração dispara eu fiquei toda
arrepiada e tudo acabou porque não
contínuo porque não deu certo
tentei esquecer tentando entender é
preciso dela aqui perto em alta as
noites eu sonhei com e ela horas no meu
celular
ah eu sentado na janela olhando lá e
começando com ela
hoje a lua taxa o olho pra lua e só
lembro também no fácil pra mim ela me
ajeito e eu achei que eu fiz mas não
corre atrás eu me doei demais eu sei que
os outros caras jamais irão assim eu
escreve cartas ou eu mandei sou eu
fiquei tão feliz como ela me chamo de
amor eu acho assim pra gente eu fiquei
tão contente ela não me queria e 11
horas eo a entender
quero mais sofrer sozinho eu não vou
ficar eu vou fazer é tentar supreender
tenho certeza ela vai amar eu vou
escrever cartas romã da flor eu vou
ficar feliz quando ele chama amor não há
chance pra mim a bola faz assim eu sei
que não me quer mas você chora se eu vou
ou não está sendo fácil pra mim você me
rejeitam e eu achei que era o fim mas já
corre atrás eu me doei demais eu sei que
os outros caras jamais serão assim
jamais serão assim
galera eu queria falar você que é o
seguinte
moscou 9 já joguei aqui pra vocês se
você gostar da música sempre gostei
você está no facebook no posto do
facebook que vai ser marcar uma pessoa
nos comentários o conhecíamos teve muita
repercussão da música quem já foi
gravado no estúdio e fazer um clipe não
lhe um clipe então dá-lhe quem no vídeo
você tiver gostado comenta que você
achou da música que semana desafiou tal
lugar a ávinho combinou em tal lugar
violão tas afinada no seu que deixe sua
opinião a não ser que tentam muitos pina
caraá a hoje eu acordei minha falta de
você em casa saudade de você você
comenta aqui em baixo e aí procuro
melhorar para no clipe sai bem bem limpo
coisa não tá ligado então valeu muito
obrigado a assistir o vídeo até aqui é
nós falou